foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Tim Henson and I'm here today to
answer your questions from Twitter this
is guitar support
[Music]
asks why are bark cords so hard for a
lot of beginners bar chords are
difficult because you have to kind of
place
one finger across the entire fretboard
for some like that's just a weird
movement and really like you're kind of
hitting it on the side of your finger
versus like the the pad so if you can
hit
[Music]
and play all of those notes
cleanly and then you'll be able to get a
nice Mark Ward
[Music]
Premiere guitar asks what's a riff that
sounds easy but it's actually hard to
play John Mayer's neon doesn't sound
that difficult and then you watch him
play it it's just got his done stretched
all the way up here and it's incredible
so he Frets the root of the chords with
his thumb and then plays like just
regular chords that you would normally
do like all the way up there so it's
just it's just truly
a difficult thing to play especially if
you do not have large hands from Pedro C
Gallardo what the are Boomer bands
Boomer bends is a term coined by Rick
piato and I it describes a very specific
guitar bending lit commonly used in
music from the 60s and 70s the age of
the baby boomer
[Music]
the more twang you give it and the more
like old guy you make it sound the more
Boomerang it is I suppose but we didn't
make that term in an offensive way it
was more so just like it starts with a b
and then starts with a B so it became a
catchy phrase in that way and I think a
lot of baby boomers got upset at that
turn but that's all right because you
know it's just a way to describe a sound
play guitar underscore bass asks what
makes a great guitar solo for me how
memorable the solo is and if you can
sing the solo for example I think the
guitar solo from Bohemian Rhapsody is
one of the best guitar solos of all time
[Music]
if you can sing with it it's more
memorable than just a bunch of notes
scattered Shone baby asks can someone
send me a good guitar lesson bid on
finger tapping I'm Waking over finger
tapping right now it's one of the easier
flashier techniques which is fun because
it doesn't take a lot of effort starting
on the fifth fret and the eighth fret of
the B string and then 12 with your right
hand and the way that you fret these
notes you need to be in the middle of
the Fret I want her to get a clean no
once you can do that
[Music]
and you just speed it up
start with that sequence but yeah that's
tapping Sage of quay asks upgrade versus
upscale is upgrading a cheap guitar
worth it or are expensive guitar is just
a scam I personally do not think that
expensive guitars are a scam I think
after a certain price point that's about
as good as the guitar is going to get
you can find really really great guitars
with what I call Mojo those instruments
just have a great feeling you can find
those for under five hundred dollars
thousand to fifteen hundred dollar Mark
is where you're going to have like a
fairly like intermediate it's going to
be a good guitar and then after two
thousand dollars and up is kind of where
you're gonna find like really well
crafted guitars and they're intonated
better so for example intonation is
hitting the harmonic of the 12th fret
and then hitting the 12th fret and how
well those match together is how well
intimated that guitar is for example
this guitar
it's pretty well intonated
if we were to pick up
if we were to pick up a cheaper guitar
and see how well this one is intonated
[Music]
so you can tell that it's not the best
insulated but it's not terrible if
you're going to be performing in front
of a crowd and you want a stable
Workhorse probably want to spend a
little bit more on your guitar Blues web
radio asks what does the tone knob
actually do the tone knob is a high cut
filter so when you turn it down it's
going to cut a lot of the high
frequencies so for example I'm going to
play a riff with the toe knob all the
way up
[Music]
tone up all the way down
so you can kind of hear the difference
between those
when I bring it all the way up you get
the full range
of frequencies fdhl ihn asks how the
is sweet picking my left hand ain't
that fast so the first thing that you're
going to want to do when sweep picking
is practice very very slow both hands
need to be perfectly in sync to go into
that motion you're going to want to
think of the pick falling
in a sweeping motion and falling back up
in a sweeping motion so once you
practice that enough you can bring that
up to speed and do
[Music]
and then sweep picking Simon V radio DJ
asks right so can the guitar players out
there explain different tunings for
guitars I can never seem to get my head
around at all so there's probably a
million different tunings out there the
most common one that you're going to see
is E standard and that is
justbe that's a great one to start with
because your scales are going to be
linear foreign
[Music]
the next most common one is probably
going to be a flat standard that one
you'll see a lot in older rock music
tune the guitar down just by one half
step so that the singer wouldn't have to
Belt as hard it just gives it a little
bit of a darker sound when it's down
tuned the next most common one is Drop D
or any dropped tuning or your low string
is going to go down a whole step nice
thing about that is that you're able to
do power chords which is the root the
fifth and the octave you'll be able to
play those with just one finger
[Applause]
[Music]
and then you'll find open tunings which
are commonly used in like math Rock and
Emo music you can kind of play easy
chord shapes but then have really
complex sounding chords Feller NJ asks
you'll like pinch harmonics I love pinch
harmonic
[Applause]
they're awesome uh if you want to learn
how to do a pinch harmonic first up
you're going to switch your pickup
selection all the way to the bridge
pickup and with your right hand
you basically take the pick and you're
going to hit the string twice once with
the pick once with your thumb for one
swift action
[Applause]
Nathan relax says I have no idea what
makes a good guitar tone and it annoys
me it has everything to do with taste
and using your ears so I remember when I
was 10 years old I could not hear what
the bass guitar was doing I just
couldn't distinguish it between the
guitar and the bass guitar and then like
just a year later I was like okay I can
clearly hear that now and I don't know
what was wrong with me now I've been on
this Earth long enough to understand
what a good mix is and why it's a good
mix listening to a lot of music and
comparing mixes and comparing guitar
tones will help you on your journey to
crafting a good guitar tone pneumonia 27
asks do I need to know music theory in
order to write songs I pick a lot of the
best songwriters of all time probably
didn't know any music theory I myself do
not know a good amount of Music Theory
and if you have any melody in your head
and you write it down you're writing
music right there so now you do not need
to know me Siri at all to write songs
okay so stack music what should I learn
after learning open and bar chord shapes
if I want to learn a finger style guitar
if it were me I would learn right hand
techniques number one
muting just with your right hand and
then number two plucking with all of the
fingers with finger Style versus a pick
you can use all of them so
dumping is a good technique which you
can bring into finger Style
[Music]
choosing your right hand techniques our
diet's 55 asks is it more important to
learn how to read music or to practice
learning by ear I guess it really
depends on what your goals and music is
going to be if you want to play in an
orchestra probably need to learn how to
read music if you want to play in a band
it's probably good to practice learning
by ear I personally think that learning
by ear is a bit more important as you
know if you're thrown into a performance
with other musicians and there is no
sheet music playing by ear you'd be
doing it no problem neradi was asks what
are common mistakes for people learning
to play guitar AKA beginner mistakes
people try to run before they can walk
let's say that you have a favorite song
and it's got like a cool guitar solo or
something in it so you learn it and you
kind of skip out on a lot of basic
fundamentals of technique and timing and
understanding how your hands can affect
the tone of the instrument I was a
runner before I was a walker that helped
push me to want to clean up my run by
going back and learning to walk
correctly so there's no right or wrong
way for anyone to learn how to play
guitar but that is a definitely mistake
that people like to make prayers for
rain asks what's a good song on guitar
to practice power chords that's fairly
easy I'm trying to learn again Iron Man
by Black Sabbath classic song one of the
first I ever learned and it's God power
chords so by definition the power chord
is going to have your root your fifth
and an octave in this case we're just
going to take out the octave and just do
the root and the fifth and we're going
to start on the seventh fret of the E
and the ninth fret of the a
[Music]
[Applause]
and it sounds great that it's such a
powerful chord the root and the fifth
the melody is going to be the same chord
shape the entire time kids not Saints
asks how the Tim Henson write
playing God like can he break it down I
started that with an omnicore an
electric instrument originating from
Japan in the 80s I kind of picked a
chord sequence from the omnichord that
sounded minor and very classical to me
so
foreign
[Music]
so those are the chords after then I
kind of just arpeggiated the chords in
different rhythmic sequences and
arpeggio is a broken up chord first
chord with a quarter note and then
arpeggiating with eighth notes
and then the second chord
arpeggiating with syncopation
third chord hitting the quarter note and
then arpeggiating with eighth notes
and then other rhythmic variation by the
time we get back to this chord
[Music]
I'm hitting a melody of
with harmonics so
and then you've got
so in full that looks like
[Music]
asks how do people freaking learn a song
by ear if you can hear the melody in
your head if you can sing the melody you
can play it by ears a good exercise is
ear training so sitting down with a
piano or any instrument seeing a note
and play the note back
[Music]
um
and also like playing along with your
favorite uh songs if I wanted to think
of Careless Whisper by George Michael I
would sing it banana
it's a fairly simple concept but it
takes some practice and with practice
anybody can get it spaghetti King 10
asks not to sound post-modern but what
makes a guitar good other than Comfort
slash playability there's something that
I mentioned earlier which is the word
Mojo I guess that's the the feeling and
how much it inspires you to create how
much it inspires you to play my first
guitar ever was a squire Strat it's 150
but it had a lot of Mojo it really made
me want to pick it up and play it other
than that a guitar can be good if it is
built really well and how well intonated
the instrument can be with shoddy
craftsmanship you'll see things like the
Frets if you were to like run your hand
and you're feeling Jagged things and
you're getting cut it's going to be not
great craftsmanship if there's like a
space between like the neck and the body
joint that's probably not a good guitar
or a well-built guitar and that's the
thing is that like it could be a badly
built guitar but still have Mojo it's
really hard to put put your finger on
what makes a good guitar and it's kind
of just a subjective thing Drea asks how
do you get an instrument to Jet for
those of you who are unaware of what
gent is it's an onomatopoeia that kind
of describes the sound of that
particular style I like to think of like
the Transformers robots like biting into
a car or something that's what a gent to
me sounds like so if you're into metal
music the closest thing that I could
equate it to would be a guitar chug so
that would sound like this
[Music]
in a gent would sound like this
to get that sound what you need to do is
take a power chord
chug it
it's just putting your palm near the
bridge and doing a chug and then what
you're going to do is move that up just
slightly and then as much power as you
can into that right hand to get it to
sound almost
and that's a Gent
[Music]
jlatcher 81 asks in a day and age when
everything has been done how do you be
original if you consume as much art as
you can as much music as you can with
contrasting genres and styles the more
original your voice can be let's say
that you like jazz and you like hip-hop
and you like country music and you
consume a lot of those different kinds
of music when you sit down to try and
create if that's what you've been
inputting your output will be somewhat
original I grew up on virtuoso guitar
playing around the time that I graduated
high school I discovered top 40 music I
started studying that and found so many
things to appreciate about that those
styles of music that's where a lot of my
sound and style comes from is mixing the
easy digestible Melodies From top 40
music with guitar virtuoso music to then
create something that didn't exist
necessarily before Andre mcclive asks
what are your favorite metal scale and
how do you like to practice them do you
noodle around with the scale or do you
target something specific when
practicing I personally like to do a lot
of noodling one of my favorite scales to
practice fairly metal sounding is the
harmonic minor scale or let's just start
with the minor scales
[Music]
a harmonic minor scale you're going to
raise the seventh so that's going to
running up and down the scales is always
going to be a good practice and then
finding musical ways to apply them and
that's all the questions I hope you guys
learned something see you next time
[Music]